là le gac qui a renoué avec le dessin
pour continuer à raconter le destin du
peintre français jean le gac bonsoir
bonsoir vite fait rentrer dans l'arbre
par l'escalier de service alors on va
essayer de voir comment
[Applaudissements]
d'abord quand tu étais tout petit avait
la vocation de lessive et donc ça c'est
l'histoire habituelle de beaucoup de
peintres redford quantité de choses même
l'ex keeper du ctig de ce n'est bien m'a
donné une bonne note même une fois 20
ouais et je crois que tout a commencé
avec sa mère te pousser oui mais pour
des raisons très curieuse je crois
qu'elle disait que les romans de délits
ouais je pense qu'il ya là dedans très
souvent le peintre légendaire qui peint
des madones et 50 cela faisait quelques
influences et que je suis c'est toujours
la faute à tous les jeudis t'amener un
beau dessin attend prof de dessin pour
ça tous les autres élèves de ma classe
devait faire de même abordé moi j'y
passais tout de même beaucoup de temps
pratiquement tout le monde je dis ces
termes sont un petit format 16 10 8 cm
comme ça et je poursuivais le
chef-d'oeuvre je prends a déjà ses
traits parts est devenu prof de dessin
oui justin ouais ce qui s'est passé 10
minutes
ouais ce qui s'est passé de fou c'est
donc été prof de dessin à exposer et le
joue enfin au moment de ta première
exposition doit renoncer à exposer tu a
relancé après alors vous dire quand même
que c'est un an 68
pire à une époque où toute la société se
remettaient en question s'était pas par
hasard donc oui c'est vrai que 68 qui
tarifs d
ces entrefaites pour moi ça a été
peut-être pas 68 parce que je pense
avoir démarré un peu avant que
l'événement historique ne se passe mais
je pense qu'il ya une atmosphère que je
pressentais jeu toujours cette
impression que les pannes sont toujours
en avance de quinze jours ce qui arrive
aux autres musiques tu as eu de
révélation c'était arrivé en bloc comme
ça tu as tu as vu un jour un peu comme
pascal ou pas vu comme valérie dans la
fameuse midget tu as vu comme ça tout ce
qui est arrivé dans ta vie bon c'est ce
que je bois dira peut-être tout de suite
c'est que comme j'utilise tous ces
éléments biographiques dans mon travail
j'ai souvent du mal à penser maintenant
qu'ils sont authentiques que ce que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur ces seules est
réellement
en fait ce qu'il est très fort c'est
cette décision de ne plus talent et au
moment où elle est prise en fait de
s'apercevoir que l'horizon
sambi d'une certaine manière c'est à
dire d'abandonner devenir artiste et on
va voir que ces amateurs ce moment là
d'ailleurs que tu as vraiment fait de la
création artistique reste beaucoup de
choses à faire et notamment par exemple
de contourner cela et au lieu de passer
son temps nationale est liée à faire le
chef-d'oeuvre commencé à s'occuper de
peintres que j'ai inventé on y arrive
avec moins de deux ans s'étaient mariés
preuve de l'esa huîtres aux enfants un
trois enfants c'est pas rien et puis
d'un seul coup tu te dis maintenant je
vais plus être parce que je vais être un
reporter qui raconte la vie de pâtes et
ce en oeuvre ça sera ça ça ça et ce
peintre pourra être idiot il pourrait
tomber s'il pourra ne pas être très fort
ce qu'il fera pour être incompréhensible
c'est finalement le peintre tels que
le grand public souvent le voit ça va
donner une liberté énorme j'étais osé
faire des choses que je n'aurais pas pu
faire un autre contexte
j'ai commencé à fermer la porte de mon
atelier en fait qui n'était qu'une salle
à manger réalité je suis sorti un peu
comme les impressionnistes
je suis allé sur les chantiers dans les
forêts les cibles bien comme ça très
vite j'ai une machine à écrire pour
tâter un appareil photo ce qui se
passait des choses qui me paraissaient
curieuse enfin je n'avais plus de
complexes je ne vais pas d'oeuvre ça a
duré à peu près trois ans tu libérer
complètement
c'est extraordinaire car à ce moment là
tu fais du reportage le dessin viendra
après pour le moment c'est uniquement du
texte et de la photo sur la vie jamais
de la peinture bien qu'on voie le
peintre qu'on en parle mais c'est de la
peinture ou sans peinture a finalement
oui il ya des séries de très loin des
tentatives très variés pariant tout ce
qui m'intéressait mais je pensais que le
parc n'était plus qu'un an et que cela
suffise à lui résumé toute l'histoire de
l'art quand j'écrivais par exemple de
toutes petites histoires idiotes par
exemple la course des facteurs à paris
que laquelle j'avais assisté
je sais pas si rien de spécial que l'on
m'a donné un coin de rue arriver le pain
voilà un continent qu'il a appelés il a
eu beaucoup de monde ils ont que c'est
le peintre français en général un seul
concept du peintre français pas inventé
ça
il est peintre un peu genre années 30 il
est un peu bcbg
son hobby c'est là enfin il ya tout un
personnage que tu as inventé à travers
ses différents personnages tu as mis
l'accent sur le peintre et puis on a
perdu en fait je crois que ce sont les
gènes seraient à ce que les lectures de
nos maires dé gironde débit malgré moi
sont retenus parce que je ne sais pas du
tout ce qu'un tout jeune étudiant mais
après dix ans de décrassage 10 12 ans le
décrassage comme tu dis sont arrivés les
pastels ses fenêtres on dit mais enfin
tu dis mais où la légende dit neil que
c'est le peintre français quitte à
pousser vers les pastels et qui était un
peu laissé faire j'avais besoin de
quelque chose de tout à fait vierge fond
quand j'ai utilisé la machine à écrire
l'appareil photo était des choses que je
ne sais pas si non amateur et quand je
suis revenu à une certaine forme de
peinture j'avais j'avais besoin de
quelque chose que je ne connaissais pas
du tout le pasteur je faisais les études
d'art en fait ce que vous considérez
comme une technique mineur plutôt pour
les jeunes filles de bonne famille reste
du temps donc j'ai recommencé avec ça je
crois que la raison du pastel c'est ce
caractère
artificielle un peu technique certes
brillante mais pour n'étant pas dans les
musées peut-être que j'ai vite et aussi
l'idée des chèques je me suis dit si je
rate après tout je rate sur une
technique qui n'est pas une parole de
l'artiste c'est une façon de tâter fille
depuis leurs études en parle qualifie au
départ le pastel
oui tu connais même sa fille avait reçu
une boîte de passe très bien sûr elle va
employer un tout petit peu puis le voir
des choses plus intéressantes à faire
dans la vie enfin cette boîte est resté
c'est moi qui a irrité très drôle
qu'elle a décidé quoi parce que voilà
j'avais commencé quelques années avant
une collection de livres populaires et
des livres de mon enfance cette
connexion s'étoffer mais je n'avais pas
idée de me servir d'un long travail de
peintre et quand c'est peu quand j'ai
découvert ce concept de boston
j'ai pensé tout de suite un pacte qui
sur la fin de sa vie on suppose un
centre d'art contemporain très très au
fait des choses mais sur la fin de sa
vie pour se délasser ou peut-être se
désencombrer l'art moderne car je sais
pas ce qu'il faut dire se mettrait à
copier en fait comme un vieux sage
orientale se soumettra à copier les
images de son enfance
c'est ce que je fais depuis novembre si
les îles du stress et les élus se disent
très sincère il sait pas la bd se sont
les seuls qui participent toutes les
quinzaines dans les années 30 comme ça
où il y avait une couverture illustrée
de trois illustrations pleines pages ce
qui me sert aussi ce sont les signes
roman
ces fascicules qui paraissait au temps
du muet
dans histoire paris c'est comme ça
toutes les quinzaines alors en ce moment
on peut voir sa chute en plan oui c'est
aujourd'hui même le vernissage
jusqu'à quand je commets de février
jusqu'au 7 3 - hypo ça se passe bien
mais c'est bon parce que mon premier et
mon seul galeristes les connu
pratiquement quand il débutait mais moi
j'étais débutants aussi je crois que
c'est le type d'association surpris par
des incidents sont bien connues les gens
départs se sont beaucoup plus facile par
la suite en pointe
pour que j'aille mieux parce que
premier tout pilote s'est fait lui même
sur la société ça n'arrive peut-être
pensé pouvoir en ce qui touche aux
échanges des domaines définis sur toi
c'est le jeu de ce genre d'interview je
pense à quoi bon je dirais que je dirais
je suis d'une modestie exemplaire mais
d'une ambition avouables et corrections
de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu